Hi, Jason.
You've used non relational NoSQL
databases in production projects.?
Hi, Martin. Yes, I have.
I've learned a lot along the way
about what works well
and what doesn't in some real life
applications.
I'll be happy to share with you.
We'd love to learn from you.
So, Jason,
we met two years ago at developer
conferences in London and in California.
I learned that you speak at conferences
about Firebase Angry Cloud,
which made you a certified Google
Developer Expert,
and you're also Google
Cloud certified professional architect.
And you run your own business 418.dev.
Yes. Martin, I always like to keep busy.
Maybe this video should be about time
management instead of databases.
It's sometimes hard for me to work
and pick up groceries on the same day.
Well, if you enjoy something
you love, it's easier to find the time.
Wise words.
Years ago, in my first job, they taught me
about relational databases that use SQL.
The data is in tables
and those tables are linked by IDs.
And any system built back in those days
used relational databases.
But then non relational databases
came along.
Well, with the web, we needed a way
to build more scalable applications.
Non relational databases filled that need.
These databases store data in documents.
Applications
only need to read a single document
for each entity,
which puts less load on the server
so these databases can handle
a lot of traffic.
Got it.
Now you've used non relational databases
in production on some major projects,
right?
Right.
And I've used them for everything
from simple mobile applications to large
enterprise Iot projects, consuming
tens of millions of events per day.
And that's what I wanted to ask, Jason.
What lessons have you learned about non
relational databases
in these real life projects?
It comes
down to three architecture decisions.
When to use relational versus
non relational databases,
how to design
a good non relational data model
and when to choose direct client
access versus an API layer.
Excellent.
Let's dig into each of those.
So the first decision on your list is
when you use relational versus
non relational database.
Tell us more about that!
Well, this is a big topic,
but my rule of thumb
is use a non relational database
when the number of reads is much greater
than the number of fronts.
Could you give us an example?
So a consumer facing user interface
might be a good example.
In many web apps and mobile apps,
there can be hundreds
or even thousands of times
more reads than writes.
Mm hmm.
Yeah,
I recognize that in my own app usage.
If most database operations
are read operations
a non relational database can be faster
and cheaper.
The data is denormalized,
which means no complex joins.
Those joins between tables
can lead to slow performance
and increased
cost in regular relational databases. Hmm.
All right.
I've written some pretty hairy SQL joins
in relational databases in previous jobs.
Also, non relational databases
often require less code to integrate with.
That means higher developer productivity.
And there are serverless
non relational databases,
which means less operations work once
the app is up and running.
That sounds pretty good.
Would you ever use a relational database
like I was taught back in my first job?
Yes. Relational databases are great
for tasks where you are making many writes
or if you need to run complex queries
for things like reporting.
Okay.
Let's say a non relational database
would be a good fit for my application.
Which one should I choose?
Well, as you can see, I'm wearing
Firebase t-shirt, so I would normally
recommend Cloud Firestore,
because it's easy to deploy and maintain.
Plus, the Firebase SDK is really easy
to work with and the Firebase team
have some great tutorials
on their YouTube channel.
There are other non relational databases
in Google Cloud
platform like BigTable and Firestore
Datastore Mode,
but Firestore Native Mode is a good choice
for most applications.
Very good.
Now the second decision in your list
is about data model design.
Now I'm pretty good at designing
regular relational data models,
but how do you design
a non relational data model?
Well, first,
use the non relational database
as it's intended with collections
and documents.
Put enough data into each document
that you won't need
to fetch multiple documents.
If you use a relational data model
with entities linked by IDs, you require
more read operations which will increase
complexity, latency and cost.
Got it.
How do we decide what fields belong in
each document?
My rule of thumb is the data
model should follow the user interface.
Got it.
The data model should follow the UI.
That's a simple rule to remember.
Good roles usually are.
But I may have data
that appears in multiple places.
For example,
I might look at a vehicle document
and want to see the address of the garage
where it's parked overnight.
But this same address would also be
in other car documents.
Where should I store that common address?
In a relational database,
each table holds a single instance
of some data and they are connected
together with joins.
That makes it easy to write a field,
but it adds load to the server
with every single read
because multiple tables have to be joined
in a non relational database
we can save on processing time
and cost by replicating the data.
So to answer your question,
we copied the address
to each vehicle's document.
We call this denormalization.
I see how that would make for fast reads.
You only read one document.
But what happens
when we need to update that address?
Do we have to change it
in every single document? Yes.
We will have to update every document
where this data appears.
And how is that efficient to update it in
multiple places?
Well, Martin,
as we discussed earlier in an application
where the number of reads far outweighs
the number of rights,
we have to make a tradeoff
When we denormalize,
the data must be copied
whenever an update is made.
However, Cloud Firestore
makes this really easy
for us
using update triggers and Cloud Functions.
I like Cloud Functions.
Tell me how you designed this!
So when you update a document
in Firestore, it can trigger a Cloud
Function.
That Cloud Function can read the updated
garage address,
and update each of the vehicle's documents
in that garage with the new address.
Great.
I like that the trigger does
this automatically so the app developer
doesn't have to remember to do it
every time they update a document.
Now, your third
design decision from your list,
that is to choose
direct client access versus an API layer.
What does that mean?
Well, there are two ways
that client apps can access Firestore:
through a server side
API layer that you build yourself
or directly from the client
using the Firebase SDK.
Right.
I have accessed Firestore directly
from a web client, in a previous project.
I avoided writing a lot of server side
code that way!
That's one great advantage
of accessing Firestore from the client.
If you have to write less code,
you will get your app to market sooner.
Also, less code means lower maintenance
costs and hopefully fewer bugs.
And there are Firestore SDKs for Web, iOS,
Android, Flutter and Unity.
That's right.
It takes a lot of work
to build a production API
that can handle things
like spotty internet connections,
caching, attacks, load balancing,
authentication and authorization.
The Firebase SDKs take care of all of that
for you.
Right.
Just last week I had to build an API
that implemented paging
and just a simple thing like that, is
pretty complex
to test it and write all the code for it.
I wouldn't want to have to build
all of the other things
you mentioned for every API I build.
Yes, indeed.
And another great advantage of direct
client access with the Firebase SDK is
that clients can be notified in real time
when your data changes in Firestore.
So let's revisit our fleet management app.
If each car has a GPS device
and reports its location,
you could display a map
that shows all the cars in real time.
Whenever a car's position is updated
by Firestore,
it will then push the update
to all web and mobile apps
so they can adjust that car's position
on the map in real time.
Very nice.
But if users are accessing the database
directly, how do you handle authorization?
If you use the Firebase SDK, you define
security rules
and these handle the authorization.
The rules tell Firestore who is allowed
to read
or write each document in the database
based on the authentication token
that they get at login.
So let's go back to our fleet management
app example.
We want to keep financial details
of the car
in the database,
like maybe the purchase price and so on.
If the fields in the main
vehicle document, whoever can read
that document, can also read
those financial related fields.
By putting the finance
data in a separate document
in a sub collection
of that vehicle document
we can limit access to it.
Got it.
Direct client access sounds pretty great.
Do you use it
in all your applications, Jason?
Yes, but not for all use cases.
In our example above,
we were able to restrict
client access
using Firestore security rules.
But let's say we want to expose this data
to a third
party application
with a custom data model.
For that we can create a server side API
which will bundle this data
into a single response.
And by providing that API layer,
you make sure that both
your clients
apps and third parties can call it?
That's right.
With an API layer, it's also easier
to optimize performance and cost.
Plus, you can
remap the data model
to suit your needs, perform
maybe some simple aggregations or even
combine it with data from other sources.
But there's nothing to stop
you using a mix of direct client access
and API access in the same application.
All right.
Let's recap.
We talked about
when to use a non relational database.
Two, how to design a good data model
for it.
And three, when to use direct database
access from clients.
Thanks for sharing your expertise
with us, Jason!
Happy to share.
I've seen non relational databases
increase productivity
and performance
in many of my customers’ systems.
And where can viewers get more details
on how to create an application
with Firestore?
I know just the person to ask.
Hey, Puf, Martin and I have just been
chatting about Cloud Firestore.
Can you tell people where they can get
started?
Hey, Jason. And sure I can. Hi, Martin.
You can find lots and loads of resources
on the Firebase YouTube channel
and at firebase.google.com where there are
many fantastic guides and tutorials.
Thanks, Puf. It was great to see you.
You too, Jason, and thanks, Martin,
for letting me gatecrash your show!
No problem. You're always welcome.
And thank you, everyone for watching.
If you have questions for Jason
or me, please, I had a comment below.
Also, let me know
if there are other serverless topics
you'd like to see in future episodes.
I read every single comment.
Until next time!